hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast linking t-cell opponent
site to phenotype with TCR single-cell
RNA seek presented by mics Tubbington
PhD senior staff scientist Wellcome
Trust Sanger Institute and Tapia Lombard
PhD postdoctoral fellow I am BL EDI
visiting scientist at the Wellcome Trust
Sanger Institute we are excited to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by labyrinth and sponsored by
fluid I'm we strive to partner with
customers to pursue truth in a complex
biological world leveraging our core
technologies micro fluidics and math
cytometry we provide simplified and
elegant workflows for single cell
approaches to genomics and proteomics
applications our c1 and bio mark systems
enable the field of single-cell genomics
partner with us on your quest to
characterize and understand individual
cell function engage with us at fluid
I'm calm I am 2d Oracle of roots and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen I'll answer as many questions
as we can
at the end of the presentation also
please notice that you'll be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the slide window just click on
the screen icon located on the lower
right and finally if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation just
click on the support button at the top
right of the presentation window or use
the Q&A button to let us know you're
having a problem thank you
before we hear from the presenters I
would like to introduce Maxine mcclain
PhD field application scientist for
fluid I
hi thank you Judy before we hear from
Mike in Tokyo I am just going to give a
brief overview of the system that they
used to collect the single-cell data
what we have end is my audio okay I'm
going to okay great thank you I so this
is you know single cell heterogeneity is
is nothing new to the field of
immunology not only do you have you know
we are subpopulations but it's the
complex interplay of these different
cell types that makes up the
immunological response and and so this
has very much been single-cell
resolution has very much been part of
the paradigm and studying immunological
physiology and this is particularly true
with live flow cytometry which looks at
protein expression and phosphorylation
at the single cell level and this has
been the standard for you know for
decades now the c14 single-cell genomics
is really the the genomics counterpart
to that single cell level protein
expression and and just to take a I mean
this is relevant to what Mike on top you
are going to be talking about one aspect
of the immune response is looking at
clonal expansion you have a t-cell with
its TCR and it recognizes its cognate
antigen and initiates a clonal response
of cells of different phenotypes and the
trick is that you know there's more than
one clone attack typically that responds
to an antigen response or an antigen
presentation you know or two to the MU
logical thread as a whole and so how do
you tease out those different kimono
types and and the cell phenotypes that
are expressed within those Colonna types
to really identify the clinic site
definitively you need the Alpha and Beta
chain sequence of the TCR and and this
is obtained by sequencing typically has
been obtained using targeted primer sets
and and in some instances you can obtain
some accompanying gene expression to and
first
typical Alice's but but this is
categorically at the single cell level
because it is the alpha beta chain
together that make the TCR specificity
what so you can use targeted primers I'm
that doesn't give you the full
transcriptome two and four to understand
the cell phenotype or the collection of
phenotypes that's involved in the
quantitative the response and and what
we're going to see today is is that by
using whole transcriptome amplification
not only do you not need to use targeted
primers to recover your alpha beta
cheating but you then have the whole
transcriptome at the single cell level
not only to pick out known phenotypes
but but for discovery where you don't
know what these subtypes are that are in
your clonal population and and this uses
a very specific pipeline that mike is
going to talk about called tracer but it
also uses a very simple full-length
transcript mRNA sleep workflow on the c1
and i'm going to talk about that briefly
and so this is our c1 system platform
mrna see full-length transcript protocol
uses the concepts uses the context
murder chemistry when you're doing
single-cell genomics you you know this
has typically not been something that is
easy to do you have a very small amount
of material in a single cell and you
want to recover as much of that material
as possible
and so that's the that's the challenge
what the c1 provides is a very high
quality level of transcript recovery and
it does that on an automated embedded
workflow the c1 has only been out for a
couple of years but already if you type
c1 fluid I'm into Google Scholar there
are there are hundreds of citations that
come up so so it's a it is a well vetted
workflow and it's one that's established
and and one of the things that has been
established in the literature is that
with the c1 if you're looking for
single-cell genes you detect the most
genes out of single cell techniques and
that's especially useful when you're
looking for low bond
transcripts you can also because you can
use very high-performance chemistry's on
the micro fluidics you can recover the
full length transcript and that's really
the key for being able to recover the
alpha beta chain out of this whole
transcriptome data is that the full
length transcript was amplified as part
of the chemistry and lastly the micro
flux also provide a nice QC after you
capture yourselves on our chip you can
then put that chip on the microscope and
this is something that we recommend all
users do it at the bare minimum just to
see which capture sites are occupied and
you know to make sure that your cells
are nice and viable but if you have
phenotypic information in those cells
you absolutely recommend using your
microscope to document that and and then
that can be correlated with the cDNA
after your after your application
protocol and so this is the general
workflow normally especially with the
immune cells you're going to be looking
for a certain subtype for example cd8
t-cells and you're going to use what
normally whatever enrichment protocol
you're already using whether it's bead
based selection or fax to image for a
certain population and then you're going
to load those cells onto our chip our
consumable our microfluidic chip or IFC
and and then you're going to put the IFC
in the c1 and the c1 does the capture it
also does a wash and stain some folks do
a staining of the cells on chip and then
you get after the capture you get your
chip back and that's where we recommend
that you put it on the microscope see
what your capture efficiency was and
then at that point you're ready to run
the chemistry and there's just a you
load your chemistry whatever you're
running in this instance it was the
clone sex smarter
chemistry for Emma and I see equally but
you load that on the chip and then that
is distributed into 96 reaction chambers
and so you have 96 individual
single-cell reactions that occur in on
our integrated fluidic circuit typically
that runs overnight and you harvest it
in the morning
and then you do your standard library
prior to sequencing put it on NGS
and then what is really key in this TCR
protocol is the tracer data analysis
pipeline and this is just a picture of
our chip you can see there's a little
arrow at the bottom it says Luud cells
that's where your sample goes and then
these little numbers are on the side
those are where the reagents are loaded
you know where the this pattern in the
center this you can see these little
bars and lines those are that's your
microfluidic circuit and this is
actually what you put onto the
microscope it's made out of a clear
polymer and so if you have cell stains
that are fluorescently visible you can
assess those the same way you would with
with cells on a slide and so today we're
talking about mRNA seek specifically for
the application of T cell receptor
sequencing but but the micro fluidics is
very much an open platform and there are
a number of apples the number of
applications that we have available I
mean I refer to c1 is sort of the Swiss
Army knife of single-cell genomics and I
just want to lead over to so we have a
number of protocols a fluid I'm has
developed in-house and we also have our
user developed applications of which
tracer is one and I will show you where
you can find that on our website it's on
script hub you'll see here is a tracer
what we have available is not only our
standard mRNA secret a call that you
will use with tracer but the
instructions for setting up the data
analysis pipeline and with that I will I
will hand it over to Micah Tapia thank
you very much ok thank you very much
Maxine for the introduction
so as Maxine said we're going to talk
today about some of the work that we've
been doing to try and extract a bit more
information from single-cell RNA
sequencing of T cells cd4 T cells in
this case but it would work with CDs as
well where we look at the TCR sequences
and we think about clonality and the
association between clonality and
phenotype okay so I'm going to talk
first about the method and some of these
performance characteristics and then
I'll pass over to Tapio who will be
talking about some of the biology that
we've
done with this for the proof of concept
for this work so just as a as an
introduction to the t-cell receptor
which you may well not me just remind
you that the key point here is that it's
a heterodimer made up of an alpha chain
and the beta chain and these chains are
this this protein is Hector diamonds is
found on the surface of the t lymphocyte
and these chains contain constant
regions which consists of the comprise
the transmembrane domain initially
domain at a constant domain and then
they also have these variable regions
which are really key in determining a
certain binding specificity of the
protein and really it's the interface
between the Alpha and the beta chains
that defines the antigen specificity and
we really typically even assume that the
t cell expresses just a single t-cell
receptor with a single specificity on
its surface and of course T cells do not
recognize antigen in on its own they
recognize antigen in the in the context
of its association with an MHC molecule
on the surface of antigen presenting
cell so the T cell receptor has
specificity for both the antigen and the
combination and the combination hydrogen
and MHC the peptide MHC combination okay
so if every t cell expresses a single t
cell receptor with a particular antigen
specificity then there must be
sufficient diversity amongst t cell
receptors within the organism within the
mouse or human to detect any possible
invading pathogen or other pathological
event that they need to detect to
successfully defend that organism
against infection or disease and so to
get this huge diversity it's not the
case there's a single gene for every
t-cell receptor of course there is in
fact this process of vdj recombination
which leads to an enormous amount of
diversity in the TCR from a much smaller
set of genetic material and so in this
cartoon you can see a cartoon of the
germline sequence and what the beta
locus looks like in cells and T cells or
cells that haven't yet develop into T
cells and you can see the constant
region on the right and then these
arrays of gene segments so J jeans D
genes and beatings and so during media
recombination during T cell development
in the thymus a D and a J gene are
essentially randomly
selected and they are joined together
with excision of the intervening DNA if
this occurs successfully a V gene again
from the array is randomly selected and
joined to the DJ Junction to hopefully
produce a productive and successful beta
chain and so if we look at this in terms
of its temporal regulation the beta
chain recombines first in the thymus if
this is successful in it can be
transcribed and translated to a vita
protein this then pairs with a surrogate
alpha chain put leads to signaling
events which cause a bursa proliferation
and then signal to allow alpha a
combination and so what you get what can
happen here and what's important later
on when we're thinking about clonality
is that you can have one t-cell a t-cell
that has a single beta recombinant event
and then it undergoes proliferation
before recombining is alpha so all this
protein you can have different alpha
competence and we'll come back to that
later on one more thing to notice about
the diversity that occurs during vdj
recombination is that the the process of
joining this process of recombination is
not precise the ends of the junction the
ends of the segments as they are found
in the recombined junction are not
exactly as they are encoded of the
journal ID so the ends are chewed back
by exonuclease activity and then random
non template nucleotides are added into
the junction so this means that the the
junctional region is the most diverse
region of the entire recombinant
sequence and it's absolutely no
coincidence that this junctional region
encodes the loop known as CDR 3 which
has a really large effect a large impact
upon the antigen specificity of the TCR
okay so if we think about just at the
DNA level the sequence space of paired
chains paired DNA sequences that could
possibly be generated during t-cell
development it's possible to estimate a
number maybe up to 10 to the 21
different pair DNA sequences and so this
allows us to make an assumption that no
two T cells arise independently in the
thymus with exactly the same set of
recovers at the DNA level and we can
start to think about these TCR sequences
as is essentially a barcode for each T
cell and because these are diploid
genomes there are up to 2 alpha
recombinase and two beta recover as
possible in every cell and so this was
this was our starting point of thinking
about these data and also something else
that's important is if you want to get
these page
information this information like the
Allison visa pairs that are being
expressed in t-cells which tells you two
things if you much higher confidence in
your plural relationships because you
can see more sharing gives you high
confidence which cells are genuine
clearly related but also because it's
the interface of the alfred meter the
combination of the alpha and beta that
defines antigen p.m. HZ specificity
really if you want to start thinking
about antigen specificity you need the
paired combination you need to know that
so it's entirely possible to take a bulk
population of t-cells and to sequence
the Alpha and the beta change separately
from that bulb population and that does
give you an idea of the diversity and
the clonality the present in your
population but it's not possible to take
those data and work out the pairing of
the Outland beta change really you need
to maintain the single cell envelope and
sequence the Alpha and the beat has
changed within each individual cell to
get that pairing information and so this
project really started from the fact
that in the titan group we for a while
now been sequencing single cd4 T cells
which we've been thinking of as a model
of cellular differentiation and the gene
expression events that that occur and
change the genes present changes that
occur during differentiation from the
naive T cell to one of the effector T
cell subsets and so we've been
generating single-cell cd4 t-cell RM RNA
seek data with the c1 and when I came to
the stator I really wanted to one
I wondered these TCR genes are expressed
they should be they should have reads
present in the data set but we don't
really look at them because their
sequences are not present in the
references so can we take those take our
reads assemble the TCR sequences which
we don't enrich for we don't
specifically amplify for in these data
set but can we get them essentially for
free from our single-cell RNA seek which
then gives us the single-cell RNA seek
data which can tell us about phenotype
and heterogeneity within populations but
also if we have the TCR sequences we can
think about cell lineage and flow and
expansion and maybe start to correlate
TCR sequence of transcriptional
phenotype so first I'm going to talk
about the method and what it does how it
works and then Tapio will tell you a bit
about TCR populations that we see during
an infection model which we use as a
proof of concept so this work okay so
the method starts with a pool of RNA see
Greece from each individual cell and we
first want to find the sequences that
in that pool that came from a we combine
t-cell receptor either alpha or beta
once we fished those out we want to
assemble them into content to tailor
sequences assemble going to overlapping
context to really generate from length t
cell receptor sequence then once we've
assembled the countries we want to
filter them to remove artifacts removed
from KC context remove things that are
actually from the TCR and find just the
full-length high-confidence TCR content
then we want to analyze those to say
something about what the segments are
between OU's the BMJ segments and what
the junction we need to tides out which
really tells us about the diversity of
is present so I'll go through how we do
this but first this is just a single
schematic search showing that on the
right you can see this pipeline of going
through from achieved selecting reads
all the way through to assembly in
context and on the left you can see that
we also have reads from the rest of the
transcriptome that we can use in any
your favored method for doing that
transfer terms
okay so first how do we fish out the
context well like I said these sequences
aren't annotated within the reference
genomes of reference transcript times so
instead we generate our own references
for this step and we we've been calling
them combinatorial recombinant so
whereas in a standard reference genome
you would have 21 chromosomes for us the
mitochondria for Mouse and so you'd have
21 entries in that Gmail filing in the
input file you might give to an aligner
here we make it an entry such that you
can think of it as equivalent to a
chromosome or to a transcript in the
transcriptome for every single
combination V and J that's present
downloaded from the reference annotation
in IMG T so for the alpha locus we have
256 V V gene 65 J genes which gives us
maybe 16 and a half thousand
combinations and for the BT located just
under a thousand combinations and we
want to align our reads against these
combinations to find ones that map and
maybe therefore come from T TS and so we
also want to try and get reads as many
reasons possible here deal with the fact
there's going to be some Junction
diversity so firstly if you look at the
5 prime end of the B gene there's a set
of ambiguous ending Q types so every V
gene has a leader sequence these are
somewhat harder to find
well annotating databases from the genes
themselves but we wanted to align reads
and get reads that come off the 5 prime
end of the
into the leader sequence so we put these
ends in hid to try and deal with that
likewise if you look at the three prime
end after the J gene there's a region of
constant gene sequence here again just
to absorb the reason map the reads that
come from the end of the J into the
constant gene and then we also wanted to
deal with the fact that there's jumps
from diversity and we don't try and have
every possible combination so deal with
the 10 to the 21 possible pairs at the
DNA level we just put some ambiguous n
nucleotides in here and for the beta
locus have seven ends for the alpha
locus we have a one end it's actually
pretty flexible this is pretty robust to
your choice number of ends but we do the
mapping using bowtie to sew bowtie to
isn't a liner that is very happy to
align with gaps so it will introduce
gaps into the reference or into the read
sequence and it will also align happen
against ends and we give it very low
penalties for doing these alignments and
so that means that it's really sensitive
here and we'll align any read that looks
like it might have come from a TCR okay
so we do this alignment we take reads
and we do this alignment once for each
locus once for alpha once for beta with
their specific reference work on below
once we've done that we take the reason
as a line that map and we assemble them
into context and we do this using the de
novo RNA seek assembler Trinity now this
is designed to do to know more assembly
of entire transcriptions from the whole
set of reads that you might get from a
team singing experiment but here we just
give it the reason that looked like they
came from one of the TCR as we allow it
to assemble the context and then we let
it run we run it and we see what we get
and we get output like this which is
essentially just a fast a file of
sequences representing the context and
we found when we do this that quite
often there are more than one contact
that represent a particular TCR there
are contexts that don't come from tt-rs
there are contexts that are truncated
versions of TCR as well so we want to
filter these and we want to work out
what we can say about the sequences that
have been used so we do this by passing
all of the contouring sequences through
a G Plus this is a published version of
glass which is specific is
for alignment against recombined
immunoglobulin sequences idea b-cell
receptor sequence or T so such sequences
and like any other version at blast it
gives you eval use which give you an
idea of how good the alignment is so we
use those to filter out the things
aren't actually TC RS and we also make
sure we collapse down the places where
more than one content rep since the same
T cell receptor sequence so once you've
done that we end up with what we think
are a high confidence set of T cell
receptor sequences and the output looks
something like this so for a particular
cell for TCR for the beta locus we have
two contexts and these countries contain
this set of V D&J genes and you can see
in the second contact at the bottom that
the D segment hasn't been identified and
this is very common because the D
segments are relatively short they can
be chewed back so much that they there
isn't enough of them to unambiguously
identify them so that's that's very
common and we've reduced the entire 350
or so base pair sequence down to these
unique identifiers which exactly
represent the sequence because TCR
sequence tt-rs don't undergo somatic
hypermutation affinity maturation like
these cell receptors we can use just the
identities that between j segments and
the junctional nucleotides to to Olympic
use to identify them and one more thing
that's important when we look at these
sequences is that due to the randomness
at the junction of these sequences
two-thirds of every possible
recombination rates are non-productive
they lead to a frameshift which means
that the protein that the gene cannot be
successfully translated for a
full-length protein and so we look to
see if there are friendships introduced
if the whole thing is in frame or if
there are any stop codons and then we
define whether the sequences are
productive or not okay so given our set
of sequences we wanted to assess the
performance of the tool to see how it
works so we used some proof-of-concept
data of single-cell RNA see from a mouse
salmonella infection experiment and
Tapia will talk a little more about this
in the second half of the talk but we
had one mouse that was uninfected at the
steady state from which we got after
quality control after microscopic
imaging with the of the chip and of
assessing the data quality we end up
with 50 cells from that Mouse we had two
mice at day 14 so at the peak of
infection from which we had 71 and 39
cells and then we had one Mouse at day
49 out passed a resolution of the
infection from which we had 116 cells so
we ran tracer on the data from these
cells and first the first thing we
wanted to look at was can we get the
full length of the TCR sequences
reconstructed yes indeed we can it be
blue distributions on this slide are the
lengths that we reconstruct from the
start of the beam to the end of the je
sequence in every cell the black dotted
lines are the interquartile range of the
lengths that we see in the combinatorial
Accomando sequences so in reality these
these would be spread wider because we
don't encode we don't deal with any
junctional diversity apart from the NDSU
ties which are always the same length in
the combinatorial nodes but you can see
here that nicely the the blue
distributions really do show that we're
reconstructing full length TCR sequences
in essentially every case and this is
this is really nice it's particularly
useful for saying the TCR alpha locus in
Mouse where gene duplication and
triplication events have led to several
v genes that are very very similar to
each other and the only way to
unambiguously tell them apart is to have
the full length of the teams have as
much sequence information as possible
and we can really do that here to get
high-confidence assessment of the
tonality okay so we are reconstructing
full-length sequences do we do it very
often we do so if we look at the
percentage of change of just the right
hand column here really the number of
cells where we see productive alphas and
productive beaters in the same cell we
see that we're seeing that in around 70
to 93% of cells and this compares well
this is about the same as people have
seen before in previously published
literature where they've done targeted
PCR amplification of single cells to
look at the T cell receptor sequence ISM
and they report between 60 and 90
percent paired productive sequencing so
we think this is working about a
sensitively as targeted PCR
amplification and that's we were really
pleased and we saw that something else
on sensitivity the
we sequency cells relatively deeply they
were all sequence of about two million
to four million reads per cell we wanted
to check well if you reduce your
sequencing depth for a cell what do you
see so we subsample we took all of the
cells from the day fourteen mass 1 and
we subsampled those cells from above two
million reads 2 to 2 million reads to 1
million reads to half a million all the
way down to 5,000 reads and we did that
three times independently for every cell
and we asked can we reconstruct the same
TCR that we see from the full depth data
also as part of the pipeline and to
allow us to filter out artifacts we
quantify the expression of the TCS that
we see in every cell and we do this by
appending the reconstructed TCR
sequences to the end of the mouse
transcriptome and then we quantify the
reads using Callisto which is a
relatively new and very fast our own NC
quantification algorithm so here in this
figure we've plotted the expression
levels of that each TCR with the minimum
read depth required to see that TCR in
two out of three of the subsample data
sets and you can see here that 92% of
the TC RS are reconstructed pretty
reliably at a million raised for cell
which we think is a good depth for doing
single cell on NC but even if you go
down to $100,000 per cell you're still
reconstructing over 60% of the TCR so it
works actory depths that you would
typically aim to get at with a
sequencing experiment okay so we think
we can get T cell receptor sequences
using this method but are they genuinely
fair and so our colleague in the wet lab
Valentina very kindly performs and PCR
experiments to help us with this so we
we adapted in a previously published
approach from the Davis lab which used
targeted cDNA on human T cells on single
human T cells we redesigned the primes
to work for mouse and so we designed a
single constant region primer and
reverse constant region primer and then
a set of multiplex Prime's in the V
region which allow us to amplify in the
cDNA the full-length cDNA that we have
for all of ourselves we amplified up
just targeted the TCR sequences we
sequence them and we then compared to
their sequences
the sequences we reconstructed from the
RNA sequencing and so we recalled events
concordant if they had exact alignment
or if there were some mismatches outside
of the junctional region outside of the
CDR 3 which we assumed because t-cells
don't undergo it's not a cloudy mutation
we assumed that these would be just used
sequencing error and in fact there were
very few cells where this was the case
and I think the maximum number of
mismatches was 3 anyway so it was not a
large problem because event is
discordant if there were mismatches
within the CTR 3 because we couldn't and
I think if see say that those were not
genuine or if there was no alignment at
all and when we did this we found that
there were 410 concordant events which
was really nice overlap with 18 that
sequences that were only detected in RNA
seek and 35 that were only detected in
PCR something I should say about the
concordant event is that there were 19
cases where neither approach detected
any sequence and we counted those as
concordance as well so there are some
that were only detected by one method
and we wanted to try and get at what
those word just to check that they
weren't artifacts so we did some manual
inspection of the data we found one
example where it does look like
essentially it's sequencing error that
was the problem and you can see that in
these two sequences these are sequences
from the same cell differ by two g's
these however are in a long hollow
polymer gene tract and we know that
these are hard to sequence and that
these lead to sequencing errors so we're
not sure which of these is correct
but we only saw one of them and this was
nice we didn't see any other obvious
something else we did was we looked at
the expression levels of the concordant
sequences versus the discordant
sequences and we saw but either that
both in the RNA sync and in the PCR data
that the discordant sequences were
expressed at lower levels than the
concordant sequences so what we
interpret from this is that these
discordant sequences are genuinely there
but they are the lowly Express ones that
there's just less chance of detecting
them with both methods and we're just
increasing our sensitivity by having two
methods okay so we think that the data
work we think the method works we're
happy with the method and now I'm just
going to pass though it's Tapio to talk
about TCR populations that we see during
an infection model and what we can infer
from those data thank you
thank you Mike so I will just very
briefly now introduce the biological
motivation behind this work basically we
are interested in cd4 T cells because
they are the key regulators of the
immune system and they have the ability
to upon activation to undergo functional
differentiation into multiple
specialized subsets for example th1 th2
th17 and so on and so forth and this
differentiation happens in response to
the nature of the invading pathogen and
and to a largely large degree it is the
nature of this differentiation also
dictates the nature of the immune
response against that specific pathogen
and something to keep in mind is that at
the same time as the T cells
differentiate they also undergo very
rapid clonal proliferation so if we
consider any given peptide epitope we
know that there are only as few as as
few dozens of few hundreds of T cells
that are able to specifically respond
that epitope
but on the other hand these extremely
rare cells are able to very quickly
prefer ate and produce hundreds of
thousands of effector cells and of
course then when the infection has been
resolved most of these effector cells
are eliminated by apoptosis so as a
result we can consider the T cell
response as extremely dynamic so
basically when we carry out single cell
sequencing of T cells this is what we
can expect to see when we look at the
PCRs basically we can assume that all
the naive cells are going to be unique
in regard to TCR structure because they
have not undergone any proliferation and
also within the pool of the memory cells
we don't expect to see much clonal
expansion there might be some based on
the previous in logical history of the
animal but in the case of mice read in
SPF conditions this should not be too
significant
of course then among
the effector cells during infection this
is completely different and we can
expect to see clones that are
significantly expanded because these
cells have been quite recently selected
in to proliferation based on their TCR
specificity and this has been very well
documented for example during salmonella
infection before so our goal was to
study the dynamics of cd4 t-cell
response against the salmonella
infection so salmonella is basically a
widely used model for for th1
differentiation in mouse and during the
infection these th1 cells play a
protective role they secrete interferon
gamma and this way they activate
macrophages in the liver and the spleen
to be able to study antigen experience
cells we sorted them based on cd44 and
cd6 t2l expression and we studied mice
first at day 14 which is very close to
the peak of the infection when the
fraction of activated t-cells is close
to its maximum and we also sorted
similar population from healthy control
mice day 0 and also we wanted to study
memory cells so we sorted CD 127 height
cells from from mice 7 weeks after the
infection when we know that the bacteria
have been already cleared and in the
following slides I'm going to briefly
show some of the data and so these are
basically single cells represented by
these pink spheres and the red and and
blue bars then within the spheres this
represent detected TCR subunits also the
red one represents this your alpha and
the blue one TCR beta and then the H is
connecting these cells represent shared
TCR strands between the cells so again
red for alpha and blue for beta chain so
this is the data from one Mouse at a t14
of infection so as you can see we could
detect CCR's from 66 in yourself and
among the cells will keep detects ever
cases where where the strengths were
with the TCR sequences were shared by
the cells indicating clonal families and
as you can see there's one that contains
as many as ten senior cells right in the
in the center and something to note is
that in almost all the cases where we
detected both alpha and beta changes
among these cells in these clones the
cells shared both of them there were
actually only two cases where cells
shared only the beta chain but like Mike
already mentioned is also biologically
possible because we know that the beta
chain recombination takes place first
and it's followed by proliferation
bursts of B cells and only after that
the alpha chain 3 combine so it's
completely possible for cells to have
the same beta chain but different alpha
chain so then when we looked at the
uninfected control Mouse as expected we
couldn't detect any expanded claws
because these cells have not done any
reason for decoration so basically these
serves as a useful sanity check for for
the data here is the summary of the data
from all of the four different mice we
studied so first is the uninfected
control and top right is the first Mouse
from day 14 which you already saw so
basically we had 10 expanded clones and
the largest one contained as many
strands in ourselves the next one in the
bottom left is then the second replicate
from day 14 and in this case we could
actually detect only for expanded clones
and this is largely caused by the fact
that we only had 39 high quality cells
from from that Mouse our possibilities
for detecting the drugs were some of
limited and the last panel is then at
the week 7
memory cells again we could detect
several expanded prototypes each
containing from 2 to 6 senior cells and
an interesting by-product of this
analysis that was in addition to these
clones we could actually detect a
subpopulation of cells that represented
completely different type of of TSS
in variant natural killer T cells and
these cells are called invariant because
they expressed a defined fixed set of of
TCR sequences and instead of binding to
class two MHC on the antigen presenting
cell these cells bind to c b1 and they
respond to for example to certain lipid
antigens presented by the APCs and the
increases can very rapidly upon
activation produce high amounts of
cytokines so they can be considered as
sort of an early warning signal in the
immune system and of course there are
some surface markers that can be used
for Island identifying and isolating
these NKT cells for example NK 1.1 and
in fact what we tried to do was we
thought it cells to be anything 1.1
negative so we tried to exclude the more
ready during during their heart sorting
but to be honest the NK 141 is not a
terribly specific marker so it's not
expressed by all NKT cells all the time
and for example it has been reported
that during salmonella infection
entities has come down regulate it and
at the same time some conventional cd4 T
cells can express it in some conditions
so basically the only truly reliable way
to identify these entities would be to
test the TCR specificity so in practice
doing tetramer staining with the with
the lipid antigen that that these cells
are known to recognize but of course in
most cases this is not terribly
convenient to do but luckily with the
tracer approach we could then study the
TCR sequences and look for this known
and KT specific TCR and this way we
could actually identify 12 contaminating
entities within our data set and of
course we could then clean up the data
and exclude these cells from any further
analysis with it so in conclusion we
could see evidence of infection in this
chromatid expansion even in these
relatively small cell populations and
from the one Mouse where we detective 66
says among those we could detect as many
as as 10 expanded clothes so once we had
identified these clones we then wanted
to find out whether there was any
correlation between the clonality and
the function of state of the cell so
basically to find out whether the
clonally related cells behave the same
way during the infection and of course
with the tracer we had both the sequence
information and still we had the full
transcriptome so this was fairly easy
comparison to do and just to remind you
we have cells from three different time
points we had the red cells which are
the healthy control and then the blue
cells are day 14 the peak of the
terminal infection and the green ones
are the memory cells from week 7 and
basically what you can see here is
independent component analysis of this
of this data so it's basically a means
of reducing by the dimensionality of the
data while still retaining the useful
biological information so one can
basically interpret the results pretty
much the same way as with for example
principal component analysis and what
you can see is that these cells are
segregated quite clearly by the time
point although there is some overlap
between the day 14 and I'm the day 49
memory cells and then 2 being further
biological insights into this we were
looking at expression of known subset
specific marker genes we started with no
genes known to be associated with
differentiated th1 phenotype so this is
basically a set of 200 or so genes that
were identified in a previous or next
RNA stick studies or bulk on a sixth uh
D and on the right you can see the
cumulative expression of these genes
that overlaid on the single cells with
the darker colors representing higher
expression and and this way we could
then identify the population of cells
which express the highest amount of
these th one specific RNAs and this way
we could identify the cells which were
likely to be the most differentiated th
one effect
I want to highlight that of course this
is by no means very specific or very
precise analysis but it's quite useful
for just illustrating the general
structure of the data and and briefly
showing the potential contained within
the data which can then be exploited by
more thorough analysis so the same way
we then wanted to identify where the
memory cells were along this spectrum of
differentiation states and there are
several markers for example here we used
ir7 receptor or the CB 127 molecule and
as expected of course this was expressed
by most of the week 7 cells but also by
some of the day 14 cells and we were
very confident that these were effector
memory cells because they did not
express central memory marker C D 62 L
or or ccr7 for example and ccr7 on the
other hand was found in most of these
cells from the from the uninfected
control so those were likely to be
central memory cells finally we were
looking into for information markers
this is a panel of seven genes including
ki-67 and we could see that these were
expressed by some of the day 14 cells so
basically these are likely to be the
early th one factors which are still in
the proliferative phase of the of the
response so basically this way we put
very roughly identify these four
functional states among the data the
early undulating each ones and the
center and the effector memory cells so
in the beginning I asked whether the
clonality somehow influenced or
restricted the functional state choices
of the single cells and what you can see
here are members of this of the single
clones of the sibling cells overlaid on
this ica data and as you can see they
are fairly evenly dispersed across all
these functional States so this suggests
that the cells of a single discipline
can differentiate in an asynchronous way
and they can at the same time
populate multiple distinct functional
compartments and we had several of such
examples and basically in all cases
where we had more than a couple of cells
from a clone we could see that these
sibling cells fell into into different
functional compartments basically
indicating that they are very likely to
differentiate at a synchronous rates so
basically in conclusion with the tracer
we could at the same time defying the
Kelowna types and then we could by
studying the genome-wide transcriptional
phenotype we could we could determine
the functional states of those cells and
we saw that the expanded clones contains
cells at multiple stages of
differentiation at the same time and and
they contain both effector th1 cells and
memory cells at the same time finally we
just want to highlight that there are
several other potential applications for
the trace which we have not shown here
in the interest of time first of all one
could study these cell fate choices in
more detail during infection for example
T helper cell subsets choices and for
example lymphocytes phenotypes and
plurality during cancer for example
tumor infiltrating lymphocytes and of
course one obvious application is
following piece and affinity maturation
by by tracking the expression of
immunoglobulin genes the same way that
here we would track the expression of
TCR genes of course finally we want to
acknowledge everybody who contributed
our our team leaders our attachment
basically the whole team and especially
the love of God and Rogan who were
really instrumental in in tearing out
the Salmonella experiments thank you
okay so I think we'll be happy to take
questions okay before we get to the
questions just very quickly I want to
thank you all for informative
presentations and I'd like to tell you a
little more about dr. stubbington1 Berg
dr. stubbington1 took his undergraduate
studies at the University of Cambridge
and then spent five years as a research
scientist for the UK Health Protection
Agency he then returned to Cambridge for
his PhD at the Babraham Institute where
he investigated vdj recombination in
developing b-cells dr. stuffington and
let the lab bench for a purely
computational postdoctoral fellowship in
Sarah Titian's group at the EMBL
European bioinformatics Institute the
group recently moved to the Wellcome
Trust Sanger Institute where sterlington
is now a senior staff scientist dr.
Lindberg completed his MSC and PhD
studies at the University of Turku
Finland during his PhD with Professor
Rita las lajas MA he studied the in
vitro differentiation of primary human T
helper cells using transcriptomics and
proteomics methods identifying new
candidate genes involved in this process
in 2013 dr. Weinberg joined the Titan
lab at me am BL EBI currently at WT s I
as a postdoctoral fellow in his
postdoctoral work he has focused on
using single-cell mRNA sequencing to
understand the faith decisions of teen
helper cells during pathogen challenge
in vivo okay now it's time for Q&A so if
you have a question you'd like to ask
doctors McClain stubbington1 Berg please
do so now just click on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window type your question
into the box it appears on your screen
and click on the send button will answer
as many questions as we have time for so
let's get started
question number one is for Mike is it
possible to use tracer for b-cell
receptor sequencing and if not any plans
to implement that yes can you give me oh
great so yes certainly that's an obvious
extension of using tracer it's not
something that we have in
at the moment it's something that we
really want to do and is definitely on
our list so one of the considerations
with b-cell receptor sequencing is
somatic hypermutation and the fact that
the D and J regions can vary due to
mutation during affinity maturation
we're pretty confident that the
alignment and contig assembly steps will
deal with that just fine because we're
not using stringent parameters at all
for the alignment step but in terms of
thinking about tonality we would have to
change from looking just for exact
sharing to a more distance based
approach to think about the networks of
as possible clones but yeah we're very
interested in that extension number two
is for you as well Mike I don't have any
bioinformatics background at all what
kind of help
how will I need to set up tracer for
myself okay so in terms of getting
tracer set up it's really at the moment
at a stage where you need to be able to
just perform single-cell RNA sequencing
bioinformatics so I think you need
familiarity with the command line it has
some dependencies that need installing
which are pretty well documented on the
github or the script hub pages so I
think you probably should speak to a
bioinformatician who or be one yourself
who's also going to be doing your gene
expression analysis data anyway I would
imagine so
we're always aiming to make it more easy
to install we we've got some plans for
doing this but yes and also just in
terms of throughput
I think obviously single-cell analysis
is better performed in highly parallel
environments so on research clusters and
things like that it runs pretty quickly
anyway so it doesn't take too much
computer
can you like this one's for you what are
the rules in which the parts of the CD
are 3 region are randomly spliced and
can see one system track that from our
system it seems there's a huge variety
of how big those pieces are okay so if
that questions about kind of how how big
of a random Junction that the the tool
can deal with that's quite interesting
so we do see differently sized junctions
in our data although none of them are
completely huge I know that in gamma
delta T cells which is another avenues I
think we're interested in going down
with this junctions can be much longer
and we need to work out how to address
that so I know I looked at some very
long junctions and IG blast can deal
with those just fine so so long as we
can assemble them and extract them from
the data we will be okay I think if you
were expecting long junctions and it was
performing poorly you'd probably want to
extend the lengths of the N nucleotides
in the combinatorial combat on files to
try and deal with that and that's again
something that we're thinking about for
the future okay Mike this one's for you
can you compare this approach with
adaptive you know seek approach when
alpha and beta paired sequences can be
obtained using bulky cell RNA seek
dilution statistical probability
approach sure so that's a that's a
really nice clever method so ours
version differs in in a few ways so one
is this I think pair C requires a
certain amount of clonal expansion to so
that you have sufficient chance of
seeing the same T cell with the same
pairs in multiple wells so that you can
deconvolute those pairs using the
statistical approach we don't need that
so we can see T cell sequences just from
individual cells that aren't lonely
expanding at all and that may be
interesting in certain circumstances I
think the other thing that we can see
that as far as I know the pair seek
approach doesn't deal with is that we
can see cells that expressed multiple
alphas or multiple beta so we can we can
see the cases where the the non
productively rearranged chain is
expressed at the mRNA level which again
helps us really to get high confidence
clonality assessment we can also see the
cases where two productive alphas are
expressed and we see that in around 26%
of cells and I think the reported
percentages around 30% so again that's
that's something that is quite
interesting we can also see the cases
which are much rarer where allelic
exclusion and the beetle locus hasn't
been complete and we can see in the
single-digit percentage of cells that
have to print or care to have two
productive fetus and I don't believe
that passage is expecting cells with
more than one alpha and one Peter
okay the next one is from Ike as well
can you review what I believe it's
confidence methods you use to assemble
in a line are those adjustable and
tracer and what's the impact of lowering
continents on the diversity one can
detect yes so at the moment they're not
adjustable we set essentially the
minimum possible penalties for bowtie 2
for doing the alignment so we think
that's about as sensitive as it can go
just if you don't give it any look any
penalty it doesn't work in terms of the
assembly we just used Trinity's defaults
which appear to work pretty well
something that I think would be
interesting to do is to maybe try
different assemblers maybe velvet and
some others but we find at the moment
that 70 works quite well so I'm not sure
we can reduce the stringency on the
assembly on the alignment sorry but
thinking about the assembly again as we
go forward to continue to develop its
tool I think that
okay this one is for Tapio would this
approach be practical if one was using
human peripheral blood and looking for
say a viral responsive cd8 cells I would
say in theory yes as long as you have a
convenient way of isolating your your
antigen experience cells and if you
consume that your sample contains a
reasonable fraction of your of your
cells of interest so I would say in
theory certainly this one is for you I'm
Takeo
what would the typical number of cells
we started with to get between 39 and
116 high quality cells for sequencing so
so I think we loaded first of all we
loaded 5,000 cells on the on dc1 chief
which is actually bit more than you done
you need the capture rate I would say
was usually about 70% to single cells so
with the T cells we get more I would say
more usually double cells then then
empty sites but these things but this
can be optimized based on your cell
numbers that you love in the chip and
then after the sequencing we have to
eliminate some cells based on routine
quality control but that's I would say
usually only less than 20% of of the
single cells that we sequence has to be
discarded at that point
maxime this one is for you how do you
decide how many cells minimum you need
from a clonely expanded population to be
loaded some may be larger than others
say blasting versus not that's one thing
I'm struggling with in my system about
how many cells it you know the question
of how many cells is is a universal
question when you're looking at single
cell data and what is very helpful to do
is to run a paired bulk reaction where
you look at the diversity within that
bulk reaction and and as you run your
single cell data the idea is that you
recombine your single cell data into one
pile and that should be the same as as
your both data and that's when you know
how many cells you run so there's not
one answer I will say normally it is
more than 96 and I'm really talking
about a couple of chips but but what we
find is you know it depends on the
diversity in your sample and so that's
why running that boat companion is
important and I can I've seen the
question this would you like Maxine I
opposed this once your nest is the same
one technique as sensitive as race PCR
say that targeted targeted approaches
are typically more sensitive than non
targeted and non targeted was the
approach that was used here with the
other go DT now that is in a side by
cell side by side you know volume same
volume same you know all variables the
same when you put a reaction on the c1
you're you're making it a microfluidic
reaction and that affords certain
benefits in in the sensitivity and and I
I will say that even side by side
targeted and non targeted on the c1
targeted is a little
better but the gains that you make by
going into micro fluidics on
non-targeted are basically they're very
close so even though the difference may
be fairly strong you know when you're
running these two non-targeted versus
for example a five-prime race and
multi-well plate format you run them
both on the c1 the targeted for example
5m race maybe a little bit better but I
mean as Mike and Tapia showed they get a
you know a very very high level of
recovery of the alpha-beta chain
comparable to you know to any other
method so you'd have to run a
side-by-side comparison to really say I
think that on the c1 these non targeted
methods though do perform very strongly
do the micro fluidics Maxine I'd like to
put this next one to you what is the
cell capture efficiency and how many
cells are you able to load per chip so
that is a number that we recommend
researchers titrate what would I have
seen from working with folks who were
running T cells on c1 is that the
capture efficiency if you're getting a
good capture is typically in a 70 to 75
percent range it and I think that the
numbers that tapioca or in the paper if
I recall if we're getting below that I
mean what I tell folks is you know if
you if your parameters aren't optimized
your capture efficiency isn't going to
me you know it's not going to be as good
as it could be and so if you're getting
for example 50% or lower you know reach
out to either your FAS or tech support
and we will work with you to bring it up
you know those numbers are for loading a
couple hundred cells per microliter so
you know so basically loading around a
thousand cells to get optimum capture
efficiency in 5 to 6 micro liter volume
now we are looking into optimizing these
parameters further that is
not a very clear that's not something
that has been titrated this is almost
from anecdotal evidence of looking at
different t-cell runs but but but it's
in that range hopefully we will have
some I you know as more folks run T
cells as we get more data we will have
some more fine-tuned recommendations and
exactly how many cells to load okay Mike
this next one is for you what's the
turnaround time for data analysis what's
the minimum number of TCR epitope
detected in single cell mixture okay so
in terms of data analysis we run this on
our cluster so we give it I think five
compute course it takes a relatively
large amount of memory I think maybe 10
to 15 gigabytes I mean this is not
larger than you tend to meet for
generally doing rna-seq experiments so
it fits within I think the envelope of
what you would need to analyze these
data to do transcriptomics as well it
tends to run the the datasets that we've
used run within half an hour per cell I
think to go from the raw reads through
to having me
the recombined reconstruction sequences
and then the wait the summary to to
generate those Network diagrams and to
summarize your entire experiment runs in
seconds so it's relatively quick and of
the same order of magnitude for anything
else you will do with single-cell RNA
seek data in terms of the numbers that
we get if I understand that question
correctly so as we showed we see
reconstruction of tt-rs
in most cells from good good quality
experiments we can reconstruct a TCR in
most cells
I've seen some datasets where the
sequencing depth has been very low so we
don't get that but I think in almost
every case we see paired productive
sequences in over 50% of the cells that
we see and the clone allottee the number
of different ones that the present there
depends entirely on the
population that you're looking at so if
you're looking in the uninfected Mouse
like we showed then every TCR is
different if you're looking in a highly
cloning expanding population such as
mean during salmonella infection then we
can see those big tomatoes we're almost
out of time so this will have to be our
last question and it goes to Tapia
thanks for the great presentation would
you please reiterate what biological
questions you can answer by having both
nucleotide sequence and functional state
of the cell thank you I think there's a
number of things that one can look at
for myself one interesting possibility
is to actually use that TCR sequence as
kind of a cellular barcode and then
study how how sibling cells originating
from from the common mother cell behave
during infection and how those cells
choose their cell fates and whether they
all behave the same way or different way
of course then if you know for example
what is the what is the the exact
epitope recognized by ourselves then
that's hugely informative for example if
you study specific antigen specific
populations for example in vaccine or
some kind of scenario related to that
thank you I would once again like to
thank Maxine McClain Mike's Tubbington
and Takeo Lumbergh for their
presentations do you have any final
comments next scene would you like to go
first yes
hi I one of the one of the things that
really excites me about this technique I
mean we we're in a new era for immuno
genomics and having the whole
transcriptome matched with the clonality
I think provides a new level of a
resolution that that wasn't really me
you couldn't there was no way to get it
but before you know in any other way you
can't take alpha beta chain and match it
back with the bulb gene expression you
really need that single slow resolution
and I think that's very promising
because I mean what I'm finding is I'm
talking to researchers is that it's
everybody not everybody but yeah there's
a lot of folks who are very much in the
discovery space and that is the real
power of RNA seek and so to find that
now we can pull the clone allottee out
of that as well I think that we'll see
this technique implemented very very
frequently so so thank you say thank you
both Mike on top it's been a pleasure to
listen to you well presented first and I
thank you I think we are really excited
about where we can go with this really
please as it works and looking forward
to investigating lots more immunology
with it definitely interested receive
emails and to help people if you're
having trouble with the tool or if you
have any questions or always that it
would we could make it better because
it's still under development and we're
going to keep using it ourselves and
people developing it so please do get in
touch
thank you all once again I would also
like to thank our sponsor fluid I'm for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go on let everyone
know that today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
November 26 2016 you'll receive an email
from laberd's letting you know when this
webcast will be available for replay
please sure that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining us we hope to see you again
soon bye